[Music]
although got away news littered the
Bloodless a bit by NYC love JK hey a
woman has been arrested after she was
identified as the pajama-wearing robber
who robbed at least six bags do people
still rob bank yeah maybe she got cap
why I should call the pajama robbers
you're wearing pajama pants
I understand like silk ones I just
imagine her in a onesie how did you keep
cool could you not like people like bank
robbers come in jumpsuits with Max like
the Batman BBB deep in it even you can
hide a lotta cash in one fell out yep
because the Pats are connected to the
stock so this isn't the net limit this
is what she looks like
as she was robbing uh she attempted six
things but she only got away with cash
from how does she Robin what did she
just cut her losses after that the
javelin car or not all she did is Panama
note she left with money Wow
so that last one she she ended up
getting cold feet
I guess we're not really cool see cuz
she did attempt it but the teller said
nah [ __ ] I'm not giving you any money
and that's what you like oh that's how a
good buyer that's all what you're
supposed to do do really that's not
protocol you're always above school and
he's usually were to get away with you
create a hostage situation I feel like
that person though was hood so they
understand Bluffs like they pass him a
note [ __ ] yo hand was [ __ ] shaky as
[ __ ] when you both did you ain't gonna
do [ __ ] right and it was like all
illegible oh [ __ ] there was like
teardrops we're [ __ ] bled the ink is
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] hold the [ __ ] out of
here with the [ __ ] I'll Rob yo ass give
me your [ __ ] money they understand
fear this is the surveillance footage
when she was robbing Tanjung and trying
to cover her face exactly so that's what
they're reporting succeeded like nothing
all she did was put glasses a bandana
and a fake mole I mean if Clark Kent
could get away with it she really didn't
give a [ __ ] cuz this looks like the
camera was my interface but maybe she's
stupid and thinks that's a really real
disguise
I like how she feels like a mole can
change everything
I know cuz look Susan past well she
looks different in this one or any other
one yeah it's kind of like those
disguises with the car changing as a
mustache she actually had up those five
banks in less than two hours she's
ambitious and then she ended up hitting
that last bank the next day so it was
been less than 24 hours
she tried robbing six weeks how much
money you should get away with it before
the first wife so she allegedly gave her
boyfriend when she got home four
thousand two hundred dollars in cash
that is [ __ ] ridiculous wonder she
had to keep going back for more 4000
bucks you saw she should have just
robbed vending machines she would have
got more money maybe there's just a lot
of money for her in one day she doesn't
know how much banks carry I think it's
just cuz I think like bank robberies as
in that [ __ ] little burlap sack with
all the [ __ ] cash in [ __ ] is a gimme
all your buddy is like $30 home how much
do they keep on like in the teller area
they got G's in there at least yeah pull
it out somehow it seemed like like even
my tents tents pastors like yeah I think
the Mac supposed to have is maybe twenty
maybe they're just like here's a hundred
dollars and you go yeah to pay change
you runs away no I do not she was
telling the tellers to give her all of
the hundreds 50s and 20s cousin hundreds
you have a bundle of time yeah just
hundreds of watch Tina I don't know if
she got away with more it's the only
amount of money that's reported is the
amount that she gave her boyfriend when
she got him out of there was holder from
a boyfriend she knows he's going to use
it in the strip club in Oakland police
got an anonymous tip which led to her
arrest
they don't need an anonymous tip are you
sure what the [ __ ] are missing all be
brought in the boyfriend and her son
which I'm not just I'm not sure hope she
had a cute oh yeah so you have mouths to
feed two lazy guys at home yeah until
they could have shrimp look at her no
and he's not at the usual places
yeah maybe have like the lunch hour
midweek discount topless bars but like
or maybe at a truck stop but I don't see
her at the local
very posh ones with the porn stars I
don't see her doing that oh yeah I see
her though doing the ones with the girls
with one leg or three teeth and that
kind of place on arch Tom nah people
must be hard all right your signs get
caught on the [ __ ] Pope no and also
too you have to always keep your body
image all the time dude that is hard
enough to lose like two pounds you
should do they always got working on
that [ __ ] and if you eat too soon before
your shift my talk on stage what if you
[ __ ] partly on that poor dude just
cost us - [ __ ] it everybody - spin down
a few Mexican food I prefer you can
enjoy those Portuguese it's a lot of
work I'm not a [ __ ] ton of upper voice
real it doesn't [ __ ] hurt everybody
you know when you see the girls they
hold it with between their thighs and
they do this and they [ __ ] spin down
it talented though there should have
been a lot of people disrespect but
whenever I'm in a strip club I'm like
that's pure talent dude what's the
difference between this and a Vegas show
humanity
it's just that they make less money in
Vegas the only difference is after the
show you can have a one-on-one with the
performer it's like a meet-and-greet but
they're just rubbing on your date I
wonder what you ladies would do you do
yes hi babe ha ha
if you needed money fast money and
you're not in the current situation
right now you guys are down and out
really really you know where the real
money is from here the real money from
lap dances don't go there be a cam girl
and probably for sure do camp you are a
cam girl would you show your face or you
just keep it here I'm for sure with you
I don't know any faceless cam girls are
a bit like away I'm all trying to hide
ride a little bit three moles how Duke
Ambrose make money get tokens so guys
the charge up it's kind of like going to
the strip club your corners in that
risky car lot they charge their account
up with money and then they give the
girl token awesome pain and I playing a
video game I just give a token Oh and
show a few inches all all the things you
could watch without paying like is it
but then if you want to pay she'll do
like different kind of stuff oh where is
it like when you're not you can go to a
private room but I never paid for it I'm
too cheap for it what would you do if
there is no no no I'm talking about like
you are it's zero zero
to pay like rent and they're trying to
jumpstart your last I got I got a fixed
[ __ ] you came to my door and you're like
look you don't know where barded I need
some money and I'm like talk to you and
I slammed the door you say nobody will
let you borrow money not even the banks
you don't [ __ ] up your credit you are
late on all your bails and you need
money right now how's it going it's like
babysitting or some [ __ ] you would even
sell drugs no he said I'm pregnant
no the baby came out the baby came out
cuz when you're playing that you're
limited or you can do yeah but let's say
the baby came out when years old I'm
gone what do you do you need money quick
and fast back oh and all of us died here
- oh you're Donna now you need money
really wait why can't I do babysitting
because that's not quickly now you need
the money now you need seven G's by a
bunt oh my god hi would you escort no
set you sugar baby right using your
noggin what about your team okay see if
we're talking about seven GS and what my
original time would not work at all
whatsoever gonna drive for uber Santa
Monica Shores no no I'll be the baby's
like being a waitress or a bartender
that is not quick money you need to make
G's per night what do you do how would I
know what to do I feel like I would I
would also be an escort because I yeah I
wouldn't want to be a camera I don't
think I tried I tried pool dancing with
like my brothers like Beyonce it was fun
but man that's it's hard [ __ ] hard
like like if I need make good money like
I know I won't be able to make money off
the pole because I don't have a skill
there's pros and cons Oh cam girl you're
entrepreneur you have your own show same
thing as being Oprah you might have to
build an audience and that might take
time because you might not be so popular
because of the competition escorts you
are more in danger because it's real
life we also got protection services and
you still have to build your clientele
because your organization the client
cells already built you're getting
[ __ ] twisted no they have this so
they have the judge organizations and
then they have this infrastructure set
up their own words and all that stuff
see guys don't really have that type in
blue it's day for paying and
that'd be a chubby funder was it I don't
know we fight again another day though
I'm just saying that I don't have the
same opportunities as you do if I'm in
trouble I can't just show my dick in
jackoff on camera
they're gonna they're gonna hate me I'm
not presentable I never got my balls man
I can't do any of that
dick bleaching it's a long process
though I need it in one month I need to
start making money right now wonder what
it feels like to be wanted for your body
ladies what that's it these people
giving you the attention ah so it's like
a creep yeah isn't it son but let's say
you've never been hit on before and even
and there's a creepy guy and for the
first time you light it up would you
feel like it's pretty nice I see so that
means you guys are [ __ ] spoiled and
the video well Jay can use phantoms I
hope you guys liked that video once
again remember if you want to be
involved just submit some article them
I'll suck your dick now but seriously
though there's more videos up there
[Music]